c'est le plus important des six
incendies qui se sont déclarés hier soir
entre 23h et minuit 25 sur saône mort
mamirolle bouclant et nancray ce matin
encore les pompiers étaient sur place
pour éteindre complètement le feu qui a
touché cette ferme en construction qui
devait être habité par l'un des associés
d'un gaec basé sur la commune il nous
sommes ici sur le sinistre le plus
important il intéressait donc
effectivement un corps de ferme qui
venait d'être terminée et une partie
habitation et d'autres locaux qui
n'étaient encore pas occuper
heureusement alors sa demande est énorme
demande mondiale plusieurs secteurs là
alors tout à fait nous avons réagi dès
le début de l'opération en engageant
donc un poste de commandement et de
nombreux moyens sur la commune de saône
pour pouvoir être dispatchés au plus
près le plus rapidement sur le lieu d
intervention au plus fort nous avions 70
sapeurs pompiers environ bâtiments
agricoles ferme maisonnette chalet de
chasse locale de déchetteries les
endroits visés sont répartis sur
plusieurs secteurs le la quasi
simultanéité des sinistres en une heure
ne semble laisser aucun doute sur leur
origine malveillantes